and minimalists hello simpletons what's
up y'all well today today oh yeah by the
way this is the minimal spod kill oh
yeah I'm Ryan Nicodemus I'm Joshua
fields Millburn and together we're the
men we need now let's keep going like
today we're gonna talk about dependency
we're gonna talk about different types
of addiction our addiction to stuff our
addiction to food our addiction to
social media and coffee and cigarettes
and alcohol and all of our addictions
and we'll address the shame that
accompanies addiction quite often and
we're gonna do that today with today's
guest 1 mark Allen is here hi thank you
for being here
I'm really grateful now you are the
author of this book I'll hold it up for
the YouTube audience we are the luckiest
my wife is the first person who
recommended this to me yeah and so Bex
said you know you should consider
getting her on the show and and now here
you are you are and we're gonna be
talking about alcohol addiction later
but our podcast we often talk about
minimalism and intentionality and many
of the questions manifest around stuff
and in our culture we certainly have an
addiction to stuff right we have a lot
of addictions right I think it probably
best to start by talking about what what
do we mean by addiction all right yeah I
think this the simplest definition is
anything you continue to do despite
negative consequences yes so we're all
addicted to oxygen but there's no
negative constant in you to do it even
though you're it's making you suffer in
some way right okay and so there are a
lot of things we do and it's almost a
point of privilege that we we have all
of these we've access to all of these
things that we can become addicted to
right and so right now I mean I can
think of people who call into the show
or send us messages material possessions
is an addiction in fact often we call it
hoarding but it doesn't just manifest as
hoarding it can just be like online
shopping addictions and but also
addictions to food sugar and carbs in
particular you overeating and some
yes a addiction to work for sure we call
it a being a workaholic right right in
fact in our culture it is a badge of
honor cigarettes is a big one my mother
died from from lung cancer because she
smoked from age 16 to 65 and and so of
course was addicted to to that I think
there are a lot of other addictions as
well and especially in our heavily
mediated world we are addicted to social
media or addicted to attention and
status and and money or what we perceive
to be the sort of what money will get
for us for sure television breaking news
or addicted you everything every we've
got to have the news right now
stimulation yeah and so our phones for
sure like that is the the one of the
biggest addictions that there are so
many of these these addictions and we're
going to talk about about alcohol
addiction as well and I want to dive
into your story but I thought first we
would start with some questions from our
audience I think this will open it up
with some different types of addiction
our first question is from Cory in
Charlotte North Carolina what do I do
with my hoarders accumulation of stuff
that wind up on my cleats so a little
bit of background my mother has what I
would consider a shopping addiction it
has had a very negative effect on on our
lives as a family over the years up
until you know losing my childhood home
in the 2008 marketing crash was based on
the amount of credit card debt because
of the these stuff that she has the
constant need to fill her her life with
so now we live in separate homes I'm an
adult at this point and the way it's
still managing to affect me as she will
go and purchase new things that she
doesn't necessarily need so she has that
kind of hoarding quality but then on the
flip side of that she calls herself a
checkers then she wants to get rid of
the old things which in many instances
aren't even old they're barely used
there's tags on them they were of a
large purchase price in an almost guilty
fashion just based on the amount of
money that she has put forth for these
items when I'm asked if I could use them
or want them I generally say yes I try
not to but in my own beginning journey
with minimizing my lifestyle
this has become my main obstacle so I'm
wondering what is it that I can can say
to her when I really don't want these
items like how is it that I can express
that you know I I don't want these items
and I don't I don't care what you do
with them like I don't you know whatever
donate them waste your money I can't I
can't be invested in this situation
anymore so Laura there are a few things
that stand out to me when we're talking
about addiction and we're really talking
about other people's addiction here and
how it affects us with Cory's case you
know I think of Ryan if you were to come
to me with this question mm-hmm I would
have the urge to want to like to grab
you by the shoulders and shake the hell
out be like dude you're one of the
minimalists what are you doing but but
there is that that's sort of urge I know
I grew up my mother was an alcoholic so
was my father and I didn't know my
father that much but yeah I spent my
entire childhood with my mother and
there were times where I literally
wanted to shake her and say you know
you've got to stop doing this but also
realizing that we can't do that no we
can't do that I mean that the very first
page of my book the epigraph is
basically like what I wanted to be said
to me what would have been useful and
what I recommend other people say so can
I read the list it's nine things yes
it's right and wow I just forgot your
book right here we no worries I do that
all the time okay it's not your fault it
is your responsibility is this is your
thing it is unfair that this is your
thing this will never stop being
thing until you face it mm-hmm you can't
do this alone only you can do it I love
you and I will never stop reminding you
of these things mmm just like slide that
piece of paper right over I love that
that's the whole thing to say though
because you're not responsible you can't
I totally agree and there was some
there's some language here as well but
Cory is using and I think some of it is
unintentional but she refer to her mom
as my hoarder I don't if you noticed
that when she first said and so imagine
like with how to survive on mom being my
alcoholic as and that my means the
burden is on me to do something about it
and let me just say this Cory number one
you can break the cycle right and it
sounds like you have you have simplified
your own life and I will also say that
it's not up to you to determine what
other people need there's a lot of
judgment here and saying well she's
she's buying a lot of things that she
doesn't need well it's not up to you to
really determine whether or not you she
needs that maybe you don't need it but
maybe it's something that she perceives
she needs or it's some of the she
perceives will add value to her life
yeah I noticed she said she feels guilty
too so a lot of this stuff that she's
taking and it's out of guilt and you
know to the point of her mom's problems
doesn't need to be her problems I've got
written down here you know you need and
take on the burden of others guilt now
with family and friends it's hard to not
do that sometimes but in a situation
like this you have to be reminded of
that and you know I think step one for
for Cory here she's got to start telling
her mom no and that's actually the best
thing she can do for her mom I mean
that's boundaries 101 absolutely
compassionate to say no yeah you can say
no and I love what you what you have
written in your book there is you know
I'm not gonna make this my problem but
I'm gonna be here for you
and I love you so so Cory you can
totally take this approach with your mom
because every time you say yes to taking
something from your mother you are
enabling her you're giving her an excuse
to feed this addiction so set the
boundaries up and again this doesn't
mean that you don't have to love or
support your mom you can say no and
still love and support her and instead
of just saying no
yes you can simply say no thanks and
realizing that every time you are saying
yes even though it's something you feel
like you perceive you would get value
from here you are saying yes because
you're you're you saying yes to her
hoarding tendencies you are giving her
permission you're making room for her to
continue these sort of pernicious
behaviors and let's talk a little bit
about that Laura with respect to our
addictions whatever they might be let's
talk about enabling for a minute yeah I
mean that's the trickiest part you know
because the people unfortunately the
people around you they love we were
confused about what it means to love
someone a lot of times and it's a
boundary thing and we take on the
responsibility of their feelings like
she was and her guilt and just because
we don't have a problem with the
behavior will still partake in it with
them and so that gets a little confusing
like drinking you know there's a lot
lots of my friends don't have a problem
with drinking but they didn't know what
to do because I did and being around me
when I was drinking was really scary for
them and problematic so were they
enabling me were they not and at a
certain point I think that what you said
is true the loving thing is to say I I
love you but I can't have a relationship
with this addiction anymore and and I'm
worried like we're so afraid to just say
the very simple things a lot of times
you know this is what I see in a
non-judgmental way this is what I see
this is what I experience because of it
and I don't I'm not going to do that
with you anymore and then just let them
be you know it's not like you're this
and you're that and you're terrible and
and the shaming thing but well I love
what you said you said you're basically
suggesting to her to say to her mother
like I cannot take part of this
addiction anymore and whenever you're
trying to make a point or you know curb
someone's behavior or you know you're
asking for someone to change if you put
the ask on yourself so that that
language of I cannot it's not you have
this addiction and you are making my
life miserable
it's putting the the negative on
yourself and then when you say you like
that's followed by the positive
statements you're you know you're a very
loving mother I really appreciate the
way that you have raised me and thank
you for giving me a home but I cannot
participate in this addiction anymore
it's like her mom isn't like the
addiction isn't her mom of course that's
just her behavior so that that
distinction is so important you know I
can't have a relationship with the
addiction I want a relationship with you
but not with this behavior yeah Cory I'm
gonna send you a copy of we are the
luckiest I think even that first page
role will do you a lot of good I'm also
going since you're talking about stuff
I'm also going to send you a copy of our
essay collection essential there's 12
different areas of attentional living in
there and one of those areas is stuff
and it talks about how we deal with our
material possessions and I think that
will help you as well so if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of essential or if you want the
book book or the e-book we'll be happy
to send those to you as well our next
question is from Christina in Sacramento
kind of question about adding things to
your wish list on amazon.com so I was
doing really well for a month I wasn't
buying anything I wasn't introducing
anything new to my house but then I
started to me you know just cleaning
supplies or replacement items of things
that I really really liked and and I
added them to my wish list to watch like
that decreases if I was going to make a
saving so I would add a ton of stuff to
my wish list and then I would and
finding myself purchasing a lot of those
items because there if there is a
notification that they're on sale or
that the price is decreased as I added
it to my wish list and I cannot stop
looking at my I cannot I'm obsessively
looking at my wish list and adding
things to my cart and it's so easy just
to press the place order button and I'm
at a loss now and I just I just need a
little bit of a tip or advice on how to
get back on track so this brings up two
things here with
to addiction one is sort of triggers and
what triggers a relapse so we have
people who become sober my I always knew
my mom could become sober because she
quit drinking hundreds of times I think
the same is true with our sort of
consumer relapses right you know Ryan
and I are not infallible we are still
tempted by by consumerism and by the
shiny widgets that are advertised to us
via our internet browsers and and and so
we certainly struggle with these all of
these different triggers and eliminating
those triggers can we talk about that
but can we also talk about this idea of
a perfection and relapse I mean the
thing is like you can't you can't get
rid of your humanity right so I mean my
thought when I when she read her letter
was like maybe just no more shopping on
Amazon like who can control that it's
designed to you know I don't go out to
bars anymore because I'm go up I you
know there's lots of places where I
could go eat or whatever so there's no
perfection I mean in in certain types of
sobriety like with alcohol I can't ever
drink again I won't ever drink again
right that's a zero-sum game but other
things that we we actually do need like
she needs to buy cleaning supplies
somewhere or you need to eat food it's
trickier and it's more of it's more it's
an it's an inside job like you got to
know when you're tipping that point - I
think the main question is am i doing
this to distract myself for myself and
you can really feel that in the moment
or do I really need this thing yeah no
totally you know when I saw this topic
come up I was really looking forward to
having this conversation especially with
an expert on addiction because I have
totally faced like my own addiction
problems in the past and when I was
listening to Christina's question here
what made me think of is how when I was
addicted I had to really like change my
state what what I started doing was I
noticed I had a problem instead of like
doing something drastic to change
my state I just thought I could think my
way out of it and unfortunately when you
have an addiction I mean maybe there's
someone out there but you know for all
intents and purposes you can't just
think your way out of the addiction like
you've got to find a way to change your
state so would you oh yeah no I mean it
actually fundamentally changes your
brain yeah so you it it significantly
messes up I mean to put it very crudely
your brain lays tracks every time you
complete some kind of process and so she
goes in on Amazon and it feels good
right for it feels good and her brain
registers like oh this is gonna feel
good right and she's done that how many
hundreds or thousands of times and so
even though it doesn't feel good anymore
even though it's giving her negative
consequences her brains she still gets
that hit that tells her it's gonna feel
good and so no and and this is why the
shame has no place because you you're
kind of out of your mind
when you're doing this so you do have to
change your state like you said you do
have to and that requires laying new
tracks like yeah that's why I said don't
shop on Amazon you know if you have to
drive to the store and and like I didn't
go anywhere where I used to go for like
two years because I had to lay new
tracks
yeah there's old patterns or they
actually get in the way of what we're
trying to change and so a few things
that you're talking about here one is
you're sort of talking about adding
friction to the process I to will avoid
most online shopping because it removes
all the friction when I remove all the
friction I also lose traction and then I
just start sliding all over the place
right and so I don't I tried to buy
online especially cleaning supplies and
a few reasons for that one is it's
incredibly wasteful in terms of all the
shipping containers and things that they
come along with that but also I know
that once I fall down that rabbit hole
$300 deep into an Amazon order I didn't
even realize it and I'm filling up that
wish list right and speaking of the wish
list I think it's great if it allows you
to offload things that you aren't going
to buy but in Christina's case it's
actually getting in the way because
she's adding things to her wish list
that is then compounding
desire to consume so I would give I
would get rid of the wish list I would
probably get rid of online shopping
altogether at least for a period of time
not just a detox but a a sort of
decluttering of online shopping so
remove yourself from online shopping for
at least 30 days test that out as a
stoical experiment and maybe even get
rid of Amazon Prime
add some friction to the to the process
so that you know that if I do have to
buy something online I have to pay a
little bit more for shipping it's okay
you want to add a little bit extra
friction because that's going to help
you curb the obsession that you have
totally man it's funny to say friction I
reworded her question and when I wrote
down is is how do we help Christina
change her state by setting boundaries
and creating friction and I've got a few
things listed here the first thing was
like yeah delete your wish list if
that's a problem keep them keep a you
know list on your notepad on your iPhone
that or on your smartphone or just a
little sticky note on the fridge but you
still are gonna have to keep track of
what you need but yeah totally delete
your wish list another thing I've
written down is cancel your credit cards
like it might be the credit cards too
that are enabling her yes because it's
so much easier to put something on a
credit card oh I'll pay that later but
when you see the money coming out of
like your bank account automatically
sometimes that's enough to kind of help
change your state that physical cash is
even even but even better absolutely you
could one thing I've written down and
some of these are boundaries and I
understand that sometimes we have to
fast we can't really diet but so this
may not be the best option for her but
another thing I thought of is she can
put if it's a spending limit that she's
allowing herself to spend on these
supplies each month she can switch her
payment over to like a prepaid credit
card so that way she can't go over the
spending limit just one way to kind of
maybe help her set a boundary here yeah
cancel your internet for a month I mean
do you really need internet like if
you're at home and you're and you don't
have to work I know that like all the
streaming services is on there and it's
taken place of TV but Mariah and I
before she was into coding now she
having internet at home is very
convenient for her job but she hurt her
and I had no internet for months at a
time and we went to now there was then
with
in Missoula Montana and there was still
it was called I think Mike's crazy
videos so it was like a blockbuster
where you want it and it was so cool to
let go and browse and like have that
nostalgic feeling of running movies at
an auction yeah yeah absolutely
so cancer you're in our for a month see
what happens um yep one thing I wrote
down is in this might be extreme have a
friend change your Amazon password and
that every time you need to purchase
like have an accountability buddy who
who knows you knows your password yet
it's good know I've done that with other
things yeah
like just to take it off your phone to
if you have Amazon and your phone get
rid of that right away
great yeah that's a great idea so and
I'm last thing I had written on you
ready mentioned Josh was cancel your
Amazon account so some of these are
lighter approaches some of these are
extreme but Christina you do have to do
something yeah you might have to do
something extreme when temporary period
of time to figure out what is then
appropriate for you in the future and I
wish Josh and I could like have this
magic answer for her just to kind of
help her you know to change her
perspective and now she's gonna live you
know very definitely when it comes to
shopping on Amazon but it is gonna take
some real workers Seema well good news
Christina I have 16 magic answers for
you we have a free e-book on our website
is called the minimalist rulebook 16
rules for a living with less it's over
at the minimalists comm slash resources
and ryan and i don't actually believe
there are real rules for minimalism but
there are some boundaries that we've
talked about and and we put up we came
up with these 16 different rules that
help us live more intentionally with
respect to our material possessions our
time and our priorities and you can
download that for free over at the
minimalists comm slash resources also
christina since you're in sacramento i'd
love to send you or give you two tickets
to our less coast tour event there we're
gonna be talking to Tk coleman and we
have a special musical guest there Andy
Davis and Sacramento we're going on an
eighth city tour with a live podcast to
talk about minimalism we're gonna talk
to a a special guest in every city we're
gonna have live music in every city and
if you're interested in that if you're
listening to this you can get tickets at
the minimalists com a slash tour right
what time is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages text your questions
comments two nine three seven two zero
two four six five four yes indeed those
text messages go straight to both of our
phones I'm not kidding and we can't
answer every question obviously what we
do answer a whole lot of them during the
lightning round Laura this is where Ryan
and I do our best to answer every
question was just a short Cheryl but
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so people can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
they like and now you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place minimal
Maxim's com but really we can just
monitor on a bit we'll ramble on well
we'll get something that'll make it real
nice and post what's our question we got
a question from Heather here is there a
correlation between living a minimal
life and a sober life I almost said is
there a correlation between living a
meaningful life and a sober life and I
think both are probably apt questions
yes so let's define sobriety here and I
mean you obviously write about this in
your book in great detail with a lot of
stories but let's talk about sobriety
and then we can talk about minimalism as
well so my definition of sobriety or
what I think it is yeah yeah um I think
I heard the best definition it's from
this Enneagram teacher and it it is
surprising but what's your number on the
integrand seven okay what are you I am a
three what am i Josh you are seven I
believe yeah I think yeah it's like
everything just snapped my wife someone
that's good that's a good combo three
one yes um so Russ Hudson's amazing
Enneagram teacher called sobriety the
capacity to savor oh really
beautiful yeah because sobriety is often
thought of as like absence of drugs and
alcohol right yeah but it's much bigger
it's almost like stoicism or or or
asceticism we're locking ourselves in a
blank room and not allowing us to touch
anything or have any sort of pleasure at
all and that's not what we're talking
about we talked about sobriety no I mean
I wrote in the book I said it it's
counterintuitive that restriction would
offer freedom right we think that more
is better and this is the premise of all
your work
but I thought I thought you know lack of
that drinking was like everything was
gonna go colorless and bland and um and
it is given me the most freedom so I
think the that definition of sobriety I
love I think it's really being aware of
and removing any behavior or pattern
that causes you to not be present to
your life yeah I think quite often we
talk about minimalism what we're really
talking about is is living intentionally
or living deliberately with or being
more deliver with the resources that we
do have and one of those resources our
time our attention and and if we're
giving all of our time and attention to
our addictions then are we really in
control of our lives no we we feel like
I'm going to have this drink or this
cigarette or I'm gonna buy this thing or
I'm gonna eat this piece of candy
because I'm in control I want to control
that moment but ultimately it is
controlling us totally yeah it's
actually born of a very you know our
addictions are very human it's the most
human thing ever it's written into every
historical record from the beginning of
time so I think to acknowledge that that
this like the reason we do these things
is actually very intelligent you know
we're trying to survive our environment
and change the way we feel
it just goes awry it goes too far yeah
well I've got a pithy answer for you
here the simple life is not an easy life
a forest fire is easy a camp fire is
simple and I'll take that a little bit
farther here
yeah if because you can't actually have
a simple life within an easy life just
like you can't have a camp fire within a
forest fire you're not gonna walk into a
forest fire and start a campfire
it doesn't actually exist it can't exist
and it's what I would say is is a simple
life or even a sober life in a way can't
exist amongst the chaos we have to
remove the chaos so that we can savor
life I love that definition you gave us
totally my short answer is covering
emotions with pleasure is like covering
rotting wood with paint
and that's really what it comes down to
like when I was addicted I was covering
up a lot of pain a lot of discontent and
the problem with that is is that
eventually it's going to fall apart it
only lasts for a short time so you know
when I think about sobriety I'd like
yeah I love that definition that you
have because because it's like you for
give you an example I broke my back so I
was given a ton of percocet and I
instantly was like oh no like I might
have a problem with this but I need to
help with the pain so what I did is I
had an accountability buddy my wife
Mariah we have a little cabinet that she
locked those up and and every time I
needed a pain pill she would go get it
for me but I found myself not really
craving to abuse them and I guess after
sitting there kind of analyzing why this
was it's because I don't have any pain
that I'm hiding from anymore yeah and
that is I think that is the key to
living a sober life like being able to
savor but but also like when you have a
glass of wine some people can have a
glass of wine and savor that glass of
wine and they're not trying to run or
hide from anything some people when they
have one glass of wine like it causes
this chain reaction and then they start
to bury themselves in alcohol yeah so
you know do you need to be sober to be a
minimalist yes absolutely but does that
mean that you have to you know take out
every single substance quick coffee and
quit alcohol no just you have to be
honest with yourself and ask when you
use substance substances what are you
doing are you hiding or are you savoring
yeah I think it's more emotional yes
absolutely
we had a Johann Hari on the podcast and
he was wonderful and the thing he talked
about with respect to people who are
coming off of like heroin addiction for
example is the people who are most
successful they have something to run
toward a more meaningful life to run
toward can you talk a little bit about
that and in your journey of of sobriety
and and and coming off addiction but
also having something meaningful to turn
to yeah there's a whole chapter my book
called a bigger yes and
that's the that's the point of it it's
like you can only run away from what you
don't want for so long eventually you
have to run something towards something
you do want or else it's what what is
this for you know right and for me it
took some digging to find that right
because if you are very deep into an
addiction there is a blanket numbness
over everything and so it takes a while
for your your desires to emerge again
for your to self to emerge and a lot of
times you have to figure out who you are
like what's going on in there what do
you even want um but my experience I
think the most telling quote and it
relates to this is there's this quote by
the Gospel of Thomas and it says if you
bring forth what is within you so you
say your potential what you bring forth
will save you if you do not bring forth
what is within you because of addictions
or whatever what you do not bring forth
will destroy you and so to me that quote
just lit me up because it was like oh
that's that's gonna save me and this was
destroying me right like the alcohol was
the small life and so yeah you got to
chase something bigger yeah
it takes time though alright before we
get into our added value segment an hour
listener tips today looks like we've got
a bunch more surprise questions this
week where do you draw the line between
a bad habit and an addiction how do you
know when your drinking has become a
problem what I would says how do you
know when your addiction has become a
problem
how does cognitive dissidence play a
role in different addictions am i
addicted to coffee if I drink one or two
cups a day what's the best way to bring
up addiction concerns with a loved one
in a supportive way we're also going to
talk about boundaries we're gonna talk
about how to remove the stigma from
redic and from recovery we're gonna talk
about 12-step programs and plus a bunch
more questions for Laura plus we're
gonna talk about porn addiction and pain
pill addiction and so much more and if
you want to hear all that listen to this
week's maximal episode that's right your
current listen to our weekly minimal
episode but each week Ryan and I record
an entirely different much longer much
more personal maximal episode on the
private podcast which is the best way
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app find all the details at the
minimalists comm slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hey there
Alexis from New York City so something
that has made me think twice about what
I bring into my home is donating with
purpose so as I've been downsizing I've
been leaving all of my stuff in a bucket
on the floor and I've really been doing
my research to try and find places it'll
actually use my stuff and you'd be
surprised at how hard it is to find
places who will take your stuff even if
it's good stuff so in doing all of this
work I am finding meaning and purpose
and the things I'm donating and I'm
thinking twice about what I bring into
my home hey guys this is Natalie from
Colorado and this is the comment for the
minimalist fashion podcast when someone
asks how to keep clothes and good
condition when doing the 3-3-3 project
so I usually wear each item of clothing
twice unless they're actually dirty and
then I also wash clothes I'm delicate
and hang dry everything except for jeans
and gym clothes both items are washed
and garment bags to prevent snags or
tears lastly because I wear a lot of
black as well once my clothes start
fading I dyed them to revive the color
oh and one last thing I usually use
natural detergents from a0 when I store
because less chemicals equals less
damage alright y'all thanks again to
Laura McGowan for joining us today
check out her book we are the luckiest
and you can find her courses or social
media her classes everything that is
Laura McAllen at Laura McAllen
love the title his book because it
there's just so many meanings to this
because I think about like being born in
America like I think we're the luckiest
to be born in America to yet to have the
relationships I have in my life I think
man I'm the luckiest person to like have
these relationships and it yeah it's a
great title and also there's a sort of
the double meaning of I'm lucky to have
to be an addict
yeah and she talks about that in the
book so so you can even be appreciative
and feel lucky for the negative things
that are going on in life and the
behaviors that we change
going forward real quick for right here
right now here are two things that are
going on in the life of the minimalists
I know quite often we talk about
addiction we talk about having
accountability partners or a support
group if you're looking for open-minded
people near you
Ryan and I set up a hundred free local
meetup groups over at minimalist org
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes it's a hundred different cities
and eight different countries and also
if there isn't one close to you we have
an online city as well so you can
connect with people online you can
connect with people in person a lot of
these groups do one or two meetups every
month in person so you're not just
connecting online but you can also
connect face to face you can find people
who are talking about minimizing but
they're also talking about career maybe
they're talking about addiction or
relationships or community and
contribution so many things you can talk
about with other open-minded people and
then also Ryan we're we've been working
on our next film which is called less is
now which will be out later this year
and we don't have a release date yet but
in the meantime a lot of folks are
rewatching minimalism our first
documentary which is available on
Netflix but also on iTunes and Amazon
and wherever else oh good it makes me
feel man when like I see a tweet and it
says I'm watching this new documentary
called minimalism it's changed my life
and it's it's like how many years old
man but like it's still it's just really
still having an awesome effect it is and
so if you want to dive deeper with that
we have about six hours of bonus
materials bonus footage you know we
recorded so many hours of interviews and
additional footage for this film that
just couldn't make the film and we
wanted to put it somewhere and so it's
over 20 videos that I believe if you go
to minimalism film calm you can buy the
bonus materials the bonus footage there
I think it's just ten bucks so if you're
interested in in doing a deeper dive
extended interviews interviews that
didn't even make the film at all there
were great interviews like bring the
Cruz Spence man like he's such an
awesome dude great advice on dating and
he used to be like a pickup artist who
has conformed to just being a really
good awesome coach but yeah I mean there
are some really awesome people in there
any interviews that stand out for you
Andy Davis who didn't make the film
I really enjoy talking to him also Sam
Harris who was in the film but extended
interview with him and Dan Harris all
the people were in the film we have more
footage of them in the bonus footage as
well so you can find that at minimalism
film.com
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast send the voice memo via email to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails now Ryan earlier we talked about
our text number people text questions to
us now it's 937 to oh two four six five
four that goes right to our phones but
also we are gonna start doing these
unscripted events if we come to your
city we're gonna send a text message out
24 hours in advance and we'll just meet
at a random coffee shop maybe at a
public park we don't know and we'll
maybe film some of it and we actually
record the last one well we did in Salt
Lake City we're an amazing event almost
100 people showed up we just sent a text
message out 24 hours in advance so you
can just send us a text to say hey add
us to your group text every Monday we
also send out the Monday morning minimal
maxims as a nice little reminder to kick
off your week how to live more
intentionally this week you can just
send us a text message to that phone
number nine three seven two oh two four
six five four and for our added value
this week have you listened to Bieber's
new album or have a man I like the Biebs
though it's really good and it's it's
one of my guilty pleasures man it's not
even it's not a deep album but it is
it's sort of a it's almost like a love
letter to his new relationship and and I
know he went through a lot apparently
I mean I can only imagine you know we
had jennette mccurdy on the podcast and
and she had to deal with a particular
level of fame and stardom and paparazzi
following her around he was that same
level but exponential in terms of of
being followed around and being the
center of attention and and being a
child star and he has made it out of
that he has developed a marriage and
he's in love and this album
almost like a tribute to that that sort
of honeymoon period of the marriage of
being in love and it it mixes sort of
contemporary sound with what I would
argue is more traditional R&B it's like
a traditional R&B I'll mix with pop
music and it is so every song on it is
like really catchy and you really get
into it
first listen Beck's and I were listening
to it like yeah this is pretty good but
we played it again I was like oh man
this is starting to grow on me and so I
was hoping to play a song from that
album today this is forever from the
album changes and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listen y'all we'll see you next time and
minimus